[Musique]
les bleus allaient en place
allez un bon ballon à l'est
et
[Applaudissements]
à des années à
si vous deviez dire que la meilleure
qualité de l'équipe de france vous
disais c'est sa bonne tenue
la correction c'est vrai que c'est une
grande qualité qu'on ne met pas assez
souvent en avant dans le sport mais bien
sûr c'est pas c'est pas cette qualité
seulement qui fait gagner les matches et
si l'on doit en ajouter une autre c'est
la générosité n'est pas cette vanité de
croire que c'est moi qui leur ai donné
je pense que ça fait partie de leur
éducation
ça fait partie de leur qualité d'homme
et je pense que je suis heureuse surtout
de toujours préconisé cela et que sans
avoir besoin de leur dire trop souvent
ils le font de même
ils n'ont pas l'idée de gagner par tous
les moyens il joue aussi pour le plaisir
ça existe
l'équipe de faim il joue surtout pour le
plaisir et et je veux que toujours que
dans chaque match il y est saad mis en
avant ce sont des mots qui paraissent un
peu enfantin maintenant de parler de
plaisir de satisfaction de bonheur mais
personnellement je veux toujours les
mettre en avant et je crois que c'est
souvent ce qui se passe avec nous
man
c'est là
on
moi
oh
le chauvinisme et quelque chose même le
nationalisme outrancier en sport ça vous
gêne
ça nous gêne mais nous ne rejetons pas
la fête populaire la fête populaire le
saucisson le coup de rouge les
supporters cette grande kermesse nous
intéresse toujours mais bien sûr tout ce
qui est en outre en sied tout ce qui est
de mesurer
ça nous gêne un petit peu parce que nous
sommes des gens assez simple 40
sélections définitif au match
france-italie power qui ça va être le
savoir mais ce que vous avez déjà en
tête votre sélection et bien non
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser je
la connais pas moi même j'attends encore
l'entraînement j'attends un petit peu de
réflexion j'attends encore un petit peu
de concertation avec quelques joueurs et
un quart d'heure avant seulement je
connaîtrai définitivement la composition
des équipes
ça ne dépend pas du dernier entraînement
ça dépend d'autres considérations de les
sentir de savoir exactement comment ils
sont physiquement
et puis surtout parce qu'on a besoin de
discussion
mais tout ça ça se fait très vite et je
dis bien dans le dernier quart d'heure
c'est seulement là qu'on bâtit
définitivement l'équipe
[Musique]